même si j'ai fantômas y en a d'autres
j'en ai beaucoup d'autres
mais c'était fantômas parce qu'on se
voyait parier qu'en gros je discutais
avec une autre femme thon rouge était
important que je n'existais pas mais que
j'étais là c'est mignon il répond ne
t'inquiète pas je n'y a pas que l1 je
suis pas un gamin je vais pas parler
juste avec qui berne alors qu'on en a
plein d'autres qui me court après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je les ai caché que j'étais né dans le
corps d'un garçon
fait d'avoir entamé la transition je les
ai sentis comme une libération
si une seconde naissance en fait je les
ai commencé à mes dix avant aujourd'hui
je me sens moi-même à 100% je suis fier
de qui je suis devenue folle alors eve
eve lève toi
c'est vrai regardez
juste pour faire là-bas développe toi et
donc ça avec la vie merci d'être avec
nous alors f très sympathique mais eve
hier tu as été la star de ce programme
non mais c'est vrai c'était incroyable
alors tu étais donc avec quelques clics
alors tu es coiffeuse à coulon ouais
d'accord très bien m tu as tu as quel
âge à 23 23 ans alors toi donc est ce
que tu peux nous raconter quand a décidé
de devenir une femme bah en fait depuis
toujours un je suis cité tous et enfin
gelé senti en fait si je me sentais pas
bien tu te sentais pas bien grâce à six
mois avant j'avais 19 ans
nobel
ouais t'es belle entame un t elle enfin
et donc quoique sur à 19 ans tu tenais
avant je me sentais pas bien ouais non
mais mais mais même avant en fête a pris
la décision à 19 ans 9 enfin voila j'ai
commencé les démarches à dinard et là tu
es là tu es heureuse lâche trop heureuse
la chasse aux draperies enfants bref si
je suis bien merci les du mal tu as du
mal à trouver l'amour
l'amour ouais on va dire après des
relations sexuelles ya aucun problème
bien sûr à ce que les mecs ils sont
enfin il ya beaucoup de mecs qui nous
aime bien quand même fait ce jusque
s'est caché c'est dans le futur c'est
c'est vraiment c'est très très cash et
après pour être en couple après ma
demande en tant que femme transfert
accompli on va dire genre vraiment qui
est qui est bien dans sa peau que j'ai
confiance en moi et c'est bon c'est
toujours autant compliqué parce qu'ils
assument par mature 13 tu as décidé de
participer à cette émission tu cherchais
vraiment l'amour pendant que franchement
mais parce que je me suis c'est un bon
concept est tout en fait je me suis pour
mac aux genres marché à fond dans la
cause et tout c'est pour ma cause en
fait ça serait cool de de montrer aux
gens qui en fait une femme trop ça peut
trouver l'amour un peu enfin c'est pas
genre quand on est des femmes normales
fin tu regardes n'est pas enfin je sais
pas si vous voyez ce que je veux dire
que si on réussit mal si les gens ils
voyaient que mais c'est important qu'ils
soient dans l'émission c'était voilà
c'est un mauvais garçon mais non
là c'est moi et les garçons en bas je
suis né dans le mauvais parent
[Musique]
je suis né j'étais garçon maintenant je
suis une femme franche pour
son cocon jouer mes sentiments
genre sont fait que ya pas de sincérité
ça va
je vous dit à ce moment là bas j'étais
choqué en fait je me suis dit mais
[ __ ] en fait je me suis la honte en
fait c'est pourquoi j'étais venu là pour
faire avancer les choses j'ai mal je me
suis je me suis fichu en fait au
contraire ça va les faire reculer ça va
juste confirmer tout ce que les gens
pensent que
je l'avais dit j'ai rencontré une femme
avant c'était un garçon situé au conseil
de faire croire
là mon coeur ndi la retrouver parce que
sur
chanson j'ai dit ou fait surgir et
sincère oui je sais ça indique le
jugement qu'on a joué cartes sur table
maintenant j'ai envie d'aller de l'avant
avec elle donc tu qu'on ait voulu
ensemble comprend tous ensemble
[Musique]
j'en pense que cette rencontre c'est un
fake pourquoi vous connaissiez avec
taken avant y avait énormément de vidéos
comme par hasard ou les avait retiré
aujourd'hui lui aussi un jour où vous
voyez ensemble comme amis et même
peut-être ayant déjà été en couple avec
lui ayant déjà rompu nous allons nous et
ont retrouvé il ya deux versions soit
milan contre ma question aller simple
devant toutes ces preuves que vous avez
retiré aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
connaissiez y colle avant l'émission
alors je vais vous expliquer en fait par
rapport à ces photos enfin ces vidéos
qui ont été supprimés
il ya en fait les fidèles ont été faites
a pris le tournage en fait le tournage
ça a été le 3 février et en fait on a
dormi ensemble après alao au château
parce qu'en fait c'est bon tu sais si on
repart ensemble on dort ensemble après
mais là-bas au château on a confiance
était juste dormir on a juste dernis
rien ouais non et rien d'autre pas de
vrai nom nagy ce dernier
tour deuxième chose qui a heurté
certains c'est que michael sur les
réseaux sociaux sur tik tok notamment il
assume sa bisexualité n'a aucunement un
problème sauf que dans l'émission il est
quand même implicitement présenté comme
hétéro c'est ça on le voit sur des
vidéos et en se transformant avec dp rue
du maquillage et des tenues féminines
bas alors moi je vous ai gallia des
vidéos moi je faisais donc est-ce que
vous avez menti sur la nature de votre
relation au terrain perdu a expliqué en
fait moi et quelques enjeux les connu
emma je savais dirait dirait direct ans
à travers le petit taquet tout il était
dit que c'était un atout clé mais les
garçons et les femmes quand vous l'avez
connu donc avant donc l'art vous venez
vous griller
je pose les questions
l'émission se connaître quand même avant
bah oui du coup ensuite en fait quand
j'avais vu sur tip top je savais qu'il
était bon et du coup par mois ça ne
posait pas de problème parce que j'ai la
joie et qu'il avait un côté quand même
masculin comme jeudi dans l'émission
voit il avait un côté masculin et tout
donc voilà ensuite on est parti en
tunisie et on a vécu une semaine
ensemble a récemment et c'est là que
j'ai vu qu'il était son côté il avait un
côté fait une entrée très voilà quoi
très présent et moi ça m'a un peu
dernièrement il était jaloux non il
avait un côté féminin enfin dans sa
manière d'être et caetera et ou qui me
dérangeait pas mais c'est juste que ben
je le voyais plus comment il était trop
femme oui
hier soir le couple qui a fait le plus
parler c'est iman et melvin qui se parle
sur les réseaux sociaux depuis cinq ans
du problème iman est tombée amoureuse
d'un fétichiste qui drague beaucoup de
filles on va revenir à la tête ça parle
des chariots j'entends déjà humaine ça
va ça va et toi oui tu es magnifique
vraiment réagir j'aime beaucoup les
pieds oui je sais que tu es fétichiste
non je suis pas parti qu'ils s'imaginent
ont par la suite tu vas devenir ma femme
ou je sais pas fauquet les pompiers
et je peux les voir si possible on verra
ça plus tard
imed vous est éducatrice sportive à
marseille vous avez vous avez divorce à
19 ans est parachutiste dans l'armée et
vous avez fait voilà vous étiez
exactement et humaine 1 vous discutiez
avec melvin c'est ça elle a été déçue
déçue hier soir ou melvin a oublié de
raccrocher son téléphone est en fait
elle a entendu ce qu'elle n'aurait pas
dû entendre j'ai attendu une discussion
tu dis à ton ami ton ami tu disais alors
la fille que tu ne vois pas
ça dit oui c'est frank thomas ce même si
j'ai fantômas y en a d'autres j'en ai
beaucoup d'autres
c'était fantômas parce qu'on se voyait
pas ligue en gros tu discutes avec une
autre femme
je préfère regarder en ami je pense que
ça sert à rien qu'en plus
je pense qu'on est sur l'as cannes zone
ce qui m'a énervé donc c'est qu'ils
parlent avec d'autres filles tu n'as pas
tu l'as pas accepter ça et pourquoi
mais pas ça va il peut parler
amicalement avec youtube quoi j'en avais
parlé est ce que tu pars avec d'autres
femmes sur tous les
tableaux très spécial a vraiment été un
peu trop mis des sites avait été avec
elle voilà vite avec un peu trop carré
c'est ça c'est ça tu es parce que tu
étais une ancienne militaire franchement
c'est des coquetteries te dis g27 il a
24 et il parle avec deux filles pas
ça va jamais vu après une demande en
mariage non mais c'est vrai mais bien
mais
qu'est ce qu'il a dit dans ces
discussions
dans cette discussion ne vous aidera
crochet son portable son ami lui poser
la question alors ça en est où avec ta
copine iman il m'a dit oui dans son
collègue lesdits fonds thomass pardonne
parce qu à lui tout seul a répondu non
mais ça thomas je connais la
page tout ce monde là vraiment je
connaissais pas fantômas ouais j'arrive
par bourguiba il a une forme que je
n'existais pas mais que j'étais là c'est
mignon il répond ne t'inquiète pas je
l'aïe a pas que l1 je suis pas je suis
pas un gamin je vais pas parler juste
avec qui mène alors qu'anna plein
d'autres qui me court après mais voilà
il voit là il était un petit peu trop de
mecs mais vous allez
on couple ça marche en cause dans une
fiche de fréquences on va y aller même
là c'est vrai
avec elle que tu discuté pendant qu'on
se parle et au sort dépend pas du tout
pas du tout parce qu'en fait non pas du
tout c'est pas commenté la nouvelle
mariée à nice à anissa à la nicotine
ça va aller il faut signer là une maman
ours et les célibataires d'accord c'est
le marbre premier regard elle est
célibataire à quoi cécile dumas au
premier regard
et ses comptes
kadhafi mais je ne crois pas elle est
dans les parages est emballé la voilà
voilà voilà ces messieurs
[Applaudissements]
lagarde
alors donc un esata effet mario premier
regard
on va chercher on va chercher sur google
et donc toi maintenant tu es avec avec
medicine depuis combien de temps ça fait
deux mois maintenant et alors c'est
comment s'asseoir centre bell ça se
passerait bien c'est pas du tout un chat
roux c'est pas un petit garçon
franchement
dans la vie de tous les jours mais ma
compagne m'a de partout et h20 quatre
ans sans que les chauffeurs
n'ont pas pris apparemment on fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment vous êtes rencontrés est même
envoyé un message sur instagram
envoyé de message en fait le premier
j'avais vu et 2 ng répondu
[Rires]
des contents
ça va durer cette affaire
allez vous faire un petit bisou
merci d'être là anthony 30 ans et luna
avait 19 ans c'est ça mais franchement
c'est pas ce cas là et voilà luna luna
ce qu'on peut en voir il faut tenir noda
qui était très sympathique très jolie
vous discuté ensemble depuis combien de
temps depuis six mois donc elle a envoyé
le premier ça les premiers messages sur
les réseaux sociaux ouais donc après on
continue à discuter pendant six mois
jusqu'au jour après le portugal t2 la
voilà avec m6 de se rencontrer dans un
endroit magnifique profiter de ma
jeunesse mais tout en me canalise en
proposant après quand tout a expliqué la
jeune fille je veux pas deux enfants la
maison
c'est compter sans une vie de famille
s'arrête jamais c'était dans sa tête
peut-être pas vrai je suis prête à
m'occuper de sa fille comme je te le dis
je suis encore jeune je découvre la vie'
je suis allé à mon rythme du coeur je
préfère un repas recèle ce soir en tout
étaient tristes ou pas nos songes est
triste parce que dans le sens où il
n'avait recensé en plus j'aime bien bien
sûr après voilà comme j'ai dis moi j'ai
jamais vu de famille j'ai mes projets
tout sa nature juste et la raie manta
chez un bref après ça s'est fini dans le
sens où elle voulait pas aller plus loin
faute sur une famille ensemble assez sur
moi c'était le but aussi c'est quand je
le supposais la clé c'est pas la clé
pour rester à l'hôtel qu'on est ensemble
mais voilà la clé du bonheur qu'on
continue voilà les jeunes c'est la clim
bizone sortie occidentaux découvrent que
justement tu as peut-être été un peu
angoissant avec la petite moi c'est ça
ouais ce qu'elle trouvait trop sérieux
et a trouvé trois dans l'engagement
directement alors on sait que souvent
c'est les hommes qui fuit l'engagement
mais là je pense que ça a été un peu je
connais depuis six mois et tu juppé est
ressentie je pense un petit peu
oppressés par la situation le chanteur a
été mature et le coach de quoi elle a
dit ce moment je parle d'enfants de
familles c'est sûr ça peut faire peur
tut tut chez bon élève de 19 ans mais
non mais non mais tu chez moi un homme
de 19 ans et était un peu trop mon truc
tu cherchais une belle mère une
belle-mère et xenapp 6 novembre c'est
quelque chose que là je comprends je
comprends luna aussi bah oui droite
avant mais peut-être aussi construit
mais je n'y allais quand il rencontre et
ici elle est jeune et pourtant il fonde
une femme tu vois la personne soit aussi
bien sûr faire la part des choses ouaip
était lourde
c'est une jeune femme a toute la vie
devant elle et c'est vrai que d'avoir
quelqu'un qui me dit voilà je te veux
comme bel max je comprends que c'est un
cas ça dérange j'aimerais que 19 ans et
1 c'est une très jeune femme alors
légalement ya pas de problème mais
moralement je sais pas si je sais pas
c'est que j'ai joué un peu vieux jeu
accroché les gens à en tout je te le dis
jamais que si je disais si si tu
cherches est vraiment une fille tu de ta
famille kita sérieux chercher une jeune
fille de 19 ans s'est peut-être pas la
dca latine gossip n'était pas le bon
casting on surveille a rien de choquant
on sait juste que l'émission en fait ils
sont obligés de trouver des angles à
chaque fois et que là ils n'ont pas
arrêté de répéter qu'elle avait que 19
ans et que vous aviez ça a été remonté
sur mon pays trafic les sonore et c'est
pour ça qu'il a reçu des messages mais a
déjà eu d'autres candidats qui avait de
telles différences dalle et personne ne
disait rien sachez que les personnes et
en plus vous aviez anthony c'est un des
rares candidats sincère de l'émission
gens reprochent aux candidats d'être
fake d'être des comédiens et vous on
sent que vous étiez sincères et le cg ça
dommage
anthony attention ne ment pas gagné
partout année là il s'est tout à coup
nous avons débusqué voilà alors bon soir
la dame va arriver alors oui en effet
allez moi qu'avec 60 heures
la commission jean mais
il sera vite anthony
[Rires]
savalou c'est très bien merci vous a été
aussi assez on se rencontrait et oui
alors vous attendez tous le néant non
c'était une très belle expérience mais
malheureusement pourquoi vous mettez pas
ensemble
j'ai 17 ans donc c'est pas
[Rires]
écoute mais pas et oui parce que c'est
un ami un ami charrier vous êtes en
frêne john était un ami de la personne
que j'étais venu rencontre non ah ouais
pourquoi les amis de diamino hamid
compliqué après non mais c'est vrai mais
en tout cas cendres donc là d'un
attendront c'est ça vous êtes devenu
super potes comme ça ouais c'est bien ça
va super merci car vous êtes amis mais
rien n'y a rien
vous y êtes vous de vous cherchez une
relation sérieuse alors je vais vous
dire et et je connais très bien le jeu
s'est pas invitée à belle maman a
laissé
les applications de rencontrer ya
beaucoup de personnes qui s'amusent à
retoucher leurs photos j'ai déjà fait
des rencontres ça s'est très mal passé
temps après c'est vraiment la voir en
vrai c'est vrai que petites canettes
d'un mètre 60 et auxerre c'est assez
marrant
scipione
une humiliation devant un million de
personnes et chaque arrivée dans cette
émission les anciennes émissions quand
même donc elle n'est pas débile donc
c'est que elle elle a peut-être cette
force de vivre cette expérience
et si lui il veut s'humilier tout seul à
l'insulté devant la france entière est
passé lui l'idiot du village malgré tout
les lis ça laisse des traces et malgré
tout je pense à duras y compris sur les
réseaux sociaux elle a dû recevoir des
aides alors justement que ça laisse des
traces et on va falloir christopher
c'est christopher a fait l'expérience il
était avec anaïs déjà la question que
tout le monde se pose
christopher
pourquoi vous regrettez d'avoir
participé à l'émission je regrette
d'avoir participé à l'émission parce que
clairement samama limite traumatisé j'ai
très mal vécu par rapport à mon poids
déjà par rapport à l'image qu'on m'a
donnée seatelli je me suis pris avant en
direct c'est
à la télévision que c'est ça qui t'a
cécilia quoi d'autre quitte à céder
retombée après en fait l'émission voilà
parce que quand on est une personne un
peu forte à la télé tu peux à savoir à
6,6 grosses bestioles c'était menaces de
mort décidée mais il y avait quand même
des choses hauteur des gros porcs
si tu commences à écouter les abrutis ne
traite jamais
personne ne
m'a contacté parce que c'est même pas
moi qui voulais la faire on m'a contacté
on m'a dit c'est nice c'est une émission
hyper bienveillante il savait que
j'avais des problèmes par rapport au
poids et tout est mis et m'ont fait mon
image a clairement été mais ce que c'est
de leur faute parce que c'est comment
les réseaux sociaux surtout c'est pas de
la faute de la production mais à écouter
pour moi je trouve que c'est 50 50 ans
soit à huy 50 50 parce que moi par la
suite on n'a même pas appelé pour savoir
si j'allais bien s'il était vivant
quand même apprécié rexie pas donc on
reçoit plein de haine pleine de menaces
planent aussi en sort dans la rue on te
dit gros porc ou alors par exemple tu
t'es pris un râteau dans la gueule sa
parenté 6 me mais au final commande
qu'on voulait réagir au final y'a pas de
psy a pas de souci mais alors après on a
plus de souci
[Musique]
kelso face à la question qu'on se pose
est-ce que vous êtes ensemble
aujourd'hui ou est-ce que non vous êtes
chacun de votre côté et les moutons
seront bien gardées ouais elle a redit
qu'elle se répande dans les râteaux
matra membres au contraire on est restés
en très bons termes donc on a toujours
les temps je suis un peu compliqué parce
qu'il voulait à moi de l'avoir mis en
vente forcément bien sûr après on s'est
expliqué c'est stoffer toi c'était des
analystes a vu un crunch pour elle
vraiment un gros creux groupe
n'était pas assis mais mon enfant et
touba oui alors ben oui et anaïs savais
pas ce que cet ami c'était amical j'ai
un petit ensemble je venais de me
séparer après maintenant parce que l'on
fondé
il est né well as live and we ll a quel
âge un arrière d'accord elle s'appelle
comment cléophée cléophée et donc soit
vous vous en êtes où vous êtes ben là le
c'est compliqué parce qu'il travaille
beaucoup il habite loin moi j'ai mon
bébé donc si on se voit pas forcément
avec qui paris - avec un d'accord
monaco est donc vous n'êtes pas du temps
ensemble mais par contre ça peut arriver
un jour tu seulement la ja le baptême de
ma fille prochainement il va rencontrer
toute la famille donc on va voir
peut-être vous êtes des courses et à
marier au premier regard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]